>> Emily: PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
WARMED TIME AND TIME AGAIN
AGAINST ELECTING TRUMP ALIGNED
MAGA --
>> President Biden: THIS IS
THE MOST EXTREME ORGANIZATION
THAT HAS EXISTED IN RECENT
AMERICAN HISTORY.
>> THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS
DRIVEN, DOMINATED, AND
INTIMIDATED BY DONALD TRUMP IN
THE MAGA REPUBLICANS.
THAT'S A THREAT TO THIS COUNTRY.
THIS IS NOT YOUR FATHER'S
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
>> Emily: DESPITE THOSE DIRE
WARNINGS, POLITICAL GROUPS AND
NONPROFITS SPENT TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS BOASTING
THESE MAGA CANDIDATES WHO WON
THEIR G.O.P. PRIMARIES.
THIS STRATEGY COULD BACKFIRE BIG
TIME, LIKE IN NEW HAMPSHIRE,
WHERE THIS REPUBLICAN HIS NECK
AND NECK WITH A SENATOR, A RACE
THAT COULD DETERMINE CONTROL OF
THE SENATE.
>> Bret: I THINK THIS RACE IS
ONE OF THE BEST OF THAT GROUP,
THAT'S PROBABLY GOING TO GO COME
DOWN TO THE WIRE.
WE COULD HAVE LATE VOTING IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE.
THAT'S ANOTHER THING TO TAKE
INTO CONTEXT TODAY, WE HAVE SOME
STATES THAT ARE COUNTING
BALLOTS -- 7:00 A.M. THIS
MORNING.
PENNSYLVANIA, GEORGIA,
WISCONSIN, AND SO IF THESE ARE
TIGHT RACES, IT WILL PROBABLY BE
INTO TOMORROW BEFORE -- BUT
NEW HAMPSHIRE IS REALLY ONE OF
THE BEST OF THAT GROUP.
THERE ARE OTHERS THAT ARE NOT
THAT GREAT RIGHT NOW HEADING
INTO ELECTION DAY.
A LOT TO MAKE UP IF YOU BELIEVE
THESE POLLS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
RACE IN PENNSYLVANIA, BUT IT'S
IRONIC IF YOU THINK ABOUT
DEMOCRATIC SPENDING, THEN
TALKING ABOUT HOW THEY ARE
ANTI-DEMOCRACY, BUT THEY LIFTED
THEM UP.
I THINK VOTERS, THERE WILL BE A
BACKLASH IN SOME PLACES FOR
THAT.
BEFORE X ESSENTIAL, --
>> I GUESS BE CAREFUL WHAT YOU
WISH FOR, MARTHA, BECAUSE WHEN
YOU PUT YOUR MONEY IN A CERTAIN
DIRECTION, IT WILL LIKELY LEAD
TO SUCCESS.
YOU ARE MAKING SOME POINTS
EARLIER THAT I THOUGHT WERE SO
INFORMATIVE ABOUT THAT WHITE
SUBURBAN FEMALE VOTE THAT HAS
SORT OF SWUNG THE 27 POINTS
TOWARDS THE RIGHT SINCE THE
SUMMER.
YOU ARE MAKING AN ANALOGY OF
1996, SOME COMMONALITIES THEY
FEEL.
>> IT'S INTERESTING.
WHEN YOU GO BACK TO 1996, AND I
REMEMBER THE SOCCER MOMS ABOUT
TIME.
AND YOU ALSO HAD THE SECURITY
MOMS POST 9/11.
THIS HAS ALWAYS BEEN A REALLY
INTERESTING GROUP TO WATCH, BUT
WHEN YOU LOOK AT 1996, THE
THINGS THAT WERE ON THEIR MINDS
WERE WHEN ALL OF THE EXIT POLLS
CAME BACK IN, IT WAS THAT THEY
SUPPORTED PRESIDENT CLINTON'S
DESIRE TO CRACKDOWN ON CRIME,
AND ALSO A VERY SPECIFIC ITEM
ABOUT WANTING MORE READING
TUTORS, MORE SUPPORT FOR KIDS IN
SCHOOL.
I THINK THOSE WILL HIT HOME WITH
A LOT OF FOLKS RIGHT NOW, AS
THINGS THAT -- THEY ARE ALSO
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT.
I ALSO THINK THAT IT'S NOT JUST
WHITE SUBURBAN MOMS.
THESE ARE MUCH MORE DIVERSE THAN
THEY USED TO USED TO BE.
>> Harris: THANK YOU.
[LAUGHTER]
BEFORE I THINK THERE'S LOTS OF
PEOPLE FROM ALL DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS WHO -- IT ALSO
TOUCHES ON YOUNGER WOMEN WHO
ARE -- THERE WAS A
"NEW YORK TIMES" PIECE TODAY
THAT SPOKE TO A LOT OF WOMEN IN
THIS CATEGORY, AND THEY WERE
EXPRESSING DESIRE TO BUY A HOME
IN THEIR OWN HOMETOWN.
THEY CAN'T AFFORD IT ANYMORE.
THE ADJECTIVES THAT KEPT COMING
UP FOR THAT THEY WERE FEELING
STRANGELY ECONOMICALLY, AND THEN
CONCERNED.
THIS GROUP OF WOMEN SAID THEY
LIKED PRESIDENT CLINTON BECAUSE
HE WAS OPTIMISTIC ABOUT THE
FUTURE.
I THINK ABOUT THE MESSAGE WE
HEARD FROM A LOT OF DEMOCRATS,
ESPECIALLY IN RECENT DAYS, WITH
PRESIDENT OBAMA TALKING ABOUT
"DON'T MOPE, VOTE."
BASICALLY TRYING TO SAY GET YOUR
ACT TOGETHER AND BE POSITIVE,
BUT THEY HAVE NOT HAD THAT
MESSAGE.
I THINK PEOPLE ALWAYS GRAVITATE
TOWARDS A POSITIVE MESSAGE,
SOMETHING THAT MAKES THE FUTURE
LOOK A BIT BETTER.
WE WILL SEE HOW THIS PARES OUT
TONIGHT WHEN PEOPLE ACTUALLY
VOTE --
SPEAK OF THIS IS A STATE WHO,
BECAUSE OF NEW LAWS -- THAT THEY
WILL CONTINUE COUNTING NONSTOP
UNTIL COMPLETION.
WE HAVE THE FEDERMAN AND OZ
RACE, ONE COULD ARGUE THAT ALL
HIS HEAD -- MORE OPTIMISM.
>> Harris: FORMER TALK SHOW
HOST, SO HE'S GOOD AT THAT.
>> Emily: AND THE FEEDBACK
FROM RESIDENTS IS THAT THEY
BELIEVE HIM, THAT THEY BELIEVE
THAT OPTIMISM AND DEDICATION, TO
GETTING THINGS DONE WHILE CITING
A SITUATION THAT IS FRANKLY
UNTENABLE AND SPEAK OF THE
ISSUES HAVING AUDIENCES OF
PEOPLE THAT --
>> Harris: AND WHEN YOU HAVE
THAT IN YOUR BACKGROUND, IT'S
LIKE A POLITICAL CAMPAIGN AFTER
A WHILE.
YOU SEE WHAT'S ON THE GROUND AND
ADDRESS IT IMMEDIATELY BECAUSE
IT'S LIVE IN FRONT OF YOU.
I DON'T KNOW FEDERMAN'S
EXPERIENCE.
AT THE DEBATE, HE SAYS HE WON
HIS MAJOR SHIP BY ONE VOTE.
I HAVE TO GUESS IT'S A SMALL
TOWN.
[LAUGHTER]
I WOULD IMAGINE HE PROBABLY WENT
TO THAT TO THANK THEM
PERSONALLY.
THE POINT I'M MAKING IS THAT
THERE WAS A LOT OF
MISUNDERSTANDING AROUND WHAT
THAT PERFORMANCE COULD DELIVER,
AND THAT'S BECAUSE HE'S NOT USED
TO BEING ON THE GROUND WITH LIVE
AUDIENCES ON THE GROUND.
IF YOU WERE, HE WOULD NOT HAVE
SAID SOME OF THE THINGS ABOUT
CRIME THAT HE SAID RECENTLY.
I THINK THIS IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT, AND IT HAS TO DO WITH
THE COMPARTMENTALIZATION THAT WE
HAVE DONE -- NOT JUST AS
POLITICIANS, BUT AS THE
ELECTORATE.
IT'S NOT JUST WHITE WOMEN WHO
VOTE A CERTAIN WAY IN THE
SUBURBS.
THIS IS AN INTERESTING POINT
THAT YOU MADE.
I THINK THE BLACK MEN IN GEORGIA
MIGHT NOT BE THE ONLY ONES WHO
DON'T VOTE FOR STACY ABRAMS.
MAYBE, ALL PEOPLE FEEL UNSAFE
BECAUSE OF CRIME.
I DO THINK IT'S INTERESTING,
BACK TO THE POINT REAL QUICKLY,
ALL OF THE MONEY THAT WAS SPENT.
HOW DO YOU FEEL AS A DONOR,
KNOWING THAT YOUR MONEY WENT TO
PAY THE CANDIDATES AND THE OTHER
PARTY!
THAT YOUR PARTY THOUGHT THAT
THEY COULD BEAT, BUT NOW THEY
MIGHT NOT.
DO YOU GET YOUR MONEY BACK?
SPEECH OF ASTRONOMICAL FIGURES.
YOUR FOX NATION SHOW HAS BEEN
FASCINATING, REALLY AMAZING
THESE LAST TWO WEEKS.
YOU HAVE INTERVIEWED SO MANY
CANDIDATES.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS IN
GENERAL ON THESE CHANCES?
>> WE REALLY GOT TO DIG DOWN
INTO THE PERSONAL LIFE OF SOME
OF THESE CANDIDATES.
I JUST WANT TO ADDRESS THE
SO-CALLED MAGA EXTREMISTS.
APPARENTLY -- THE CROP OF
CANDIDATES IS SO WILD AND OUT
THERE THAT THEY SHOULD BE DOOMED
IN THEIR FATE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THEIR LIFE
STORIES.
SOME ARE SO-CALLED MAGA, SOME
ARE NOT, BUT THEY'VE ALL BEEN
PORTRAYED IN THAT MANNER BY THE
SITTING PRESIDENT AND THE
OPPONENTS.
THIS CANDIDATE IN COLORADO
SOMEWHAT ADOPTED -- RAISED BY
DENVER POLICE OFFICERS, BUILT A
CONSTRUCTION COMPANY ONE DOMINIC
FROM HIS BASEMENT.
IN RHODE ISLAND, SPOKE TO HIM
LAST NIGHT, RAISED BY TWO
CHINESE IMMIGRANTS, MIGHT WIN A
DISTRICT THAT BIDEN CARRIED BY
13 POINTS.
GARCIA, MONICA DE LA CRUZ --
FLOREZ EMIGRATING FROM MEXICO.
TAKING TO THE SOUTHERN BORDER
WHO I HAD THE OF SITTING DOWN
WITH.
THE LIST GOES ON.
ONE -- OUT IN ARIZONA WHO COULD
WIN.
THIS KEY IMMIGRANT FROM MEXICO
AT 11 YEARS OLD IS THE AMERICAN
DREAM.
CALL THEM EXTREMISTS IF YOU
WILL.
I AM PROUD OF THESE CANDIDATES,
AND IF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY HAS
A GOOD NIGHT TONIGHT, IT'S --
SAYING "I DON'T CARE IF I AM
DEMONIZED, THEY ARE AMERICA --"
THAT'S WHO YOU ARE LOOKING AT >>
THIS IS THE MOST DIVERSE -- THEY
HAVE EVER HAD.
>> Harris: I AM SORRY THAT
THEY FEEL DEMONIZED.
>> A LOT OF THEM DO.
>> Harris: NO MATTER WHAT
THEIR POLITICS ARE.
>> GETTING THE VOTE OF THE MACON
PEOPLE --